is there anything else i can help you  with that's it okay  this comes after diamond okay i want  this one with the baby on it okay this  is our little secret  welcome okay okay  [Music]  i have a baby inside me and i want to  take it out of me  right she want it out now please right  can you take it out no we cannot what  you say take it out yes  you end that life that that life will  die it's already dead  it's not living no it is a living  breathing  life that god has created i don't think  he's breathing  we can show you that it's breathing i  feel bad because  i was the one who put the baby in her  you don't need to feel bad i was just  trying to give my daughter pleasure  and next thing i know there is a baby  inside her  you keep calling her your daughter yes  okay is he your father  yes this is your daughter yes okay  you